David oh welcome sir wow he said it
perfect
did I yeah because people usually [__]
it up yeah I'm not gonna lie I was a
little confused like like early on I was
like is it Davido is it Davido yeah it's
David oh yeah okay thank you big fan of
your show appreciate it man thank you
you're obviously a legend man I think
when we think of like afrobeats you're
kind of like the Jay-Z of this [__]
low-key you know crazy God is good yeah
what's it like to kind of see your sound
that you've been doing for all these
years become like
the sound now you know like you know I
was born in Atlanta you know what I'm
saying okay I've always been like coming
to America but like when I became a
musician especially like coming out here
you know for shows trying to push the
music it really just started with like
just like African fans coming to the
shows right you know when we do shows
out here and then it started just you
know spreading you know like even when I
was in college and I used to play my
friends African music and they liked
where'd you go to college in Alabama
okay you know what I'm saying which
school it's called Oakwood University
okay it's uh he was raised in the South
low key yeah yeah yeah fully you know
I'm saying so even when I used to play
African songs for them I knew that they
liked it so I always knew it was always
if there was an opportunity to be heard
you know people you know [__] with it
what's it like uh because I feel like I
don't I didn't know that about you that
you were kind of you're from Atlanta and
you were you went to college in Alabama
yeah that's like the Bible Belt for real
crazy Huntsville Alabama Huntsville yeah
young I was like 60 years old in college
you know HBCU and that's coming like
straight from Lagos right you know
straight there and I remember even just
being in college
and
talking to like friends there they're
asking me like oh how so how is it in
Nigeria like right how did you get here
y'all got airports you know what I'm
saying because they were not educated
about it about what's going on yeah but
now you know so you have social media so
it's different they see a different side
of Africa when you when you tell people
like oh I'm Nigerian you know oh I love
afrobeats you feel me yeah like 15 years
ago that was not the story you know what
was like for you like can you can you
kind of pinpoint in your opinion as
somebody who you know obviously has a
crib out here and went to school out
here and was born here can you kind of
pinpoint the moment that you noticed
like America's starting to kind of take
a liking to the genre
from Atlanta Two Cities Atlanta New York
uh mainly Atlanta you know just like
even going out you know I'm saying like
like one thing I knew one of my friends
used to do he used to he was a big
baller he would go to the club and he
like spent so much money but he tell him
every time you know when you bring my
bottles out I want to hear this song
right you know what I'm saying so
the DJ's playing it you know what I'm
saying
the bottle's coming out to the song you
know and the DJ is liking the music yeah
and then that's that was like one of my
first experiences of like being in the
club and hearing it yeah and then you
know it started growing you know once
the girls like it once the girls like it
it's over it's over you know what I'm
saying so even like girls being in
recovery with a guy like yo can you play
some afrobeats
because you know girls like it right you
know let's do it it obviously became
because it was like a big big thing in
the UK first right no it was from the UK
yeah before you go to America you know
UK was like the first place to
acknowledge afrobe is like we started
doing Arenas in the UK first crazy you
know what I'm saying afrobeats UK
actually named it afrobeats so that's
like a UK it's like a 10K term but then
you know we just ran with it you feel me
that's fire man what how much um can you
attribute to Drake embracing it to to
kind of it being like easily bridge to
the U.S because I feel like once Drake
Gets behind anything for the most part
it can it can really take off I mean
there's this there's always narrative
like oh you know I'm saying afrobeats
was was definitely you know I'm saying
huge it was huge because if it wasn't he
was Drake Drake one the [__] yeah it was
ready he was like before Drake but you
know Drake is Drake right you know what
I'm saying so I'd be lying if I say you
know so he didn't put some Spotlight to
you know afrobeats you know what I'm
saying um and you know dope he's made
some dope you know records